you may have touched on this earlier but
i was hoping we could just go over again
the modes
of documentary film okay so well these
are not my modes these are bill nichols
modes
uh so there is expository
um the observational mode
which is sort of completely quote
unquote objective where you stand back
and you don't interfere
there's a participatory mode which is
the mode where the filmmakers interact
so someone like michael moore
would be making sort of participatory
documentaries
there's self-reflexive mode which is um
films that are essentially about their
own making
so there's a very famous um soviet film
from like 1920 called the man
with the movie camera is that 1920
something like that and the man with a
movie camera you watch
the cameraman shoot the film that you're
watching you watch the editor edit the
film that you're watching you watch an
audience watch the film that you're
watching
it's a film that's um sort of only
um the only truth it can offer is that
well it knows it's a movie so here's
this is the truth that i'm giving you
um it's very self-reflexive uh
there's poetic there's a poetic mode so
that's like the
uh godfrey reggio films uh koianna
scotsie
those films um they're very lyrical
am i forgetting something i feel like
i'm forgetting something five
observational participatory
self-reflexive
uh poetic then there's
um the performative which is the grizzly
man
and and um thin blue lines sort of
um and something like stories we tell
and then expository
so six i think that's right
so then cinema verite cinema verite
would be like participatory
it's just story okay yeah because it's
some of it there's a difference
i'm gonna get very pedantic but there's
a difference between cinema verite
and direct cinema direct cinema is
purely observational it's frederick
weissman
it's no interaction whatsoever
in cinema verite there's lots of
handheld camera and they're out on the
street but there will be interaction
there will be something like american
movie or the films or roger and me the
michael moore film so you brought up
werner herzog and errol morris since i'm
thinking like the thin blue line or into
the abyss
where you have multiple points of view
and i think
i got this from something you said truth
doesn't exist it's only perception
which is excellent i like that make a
t-shirt out of it yeah
especially in this day and age twitter
and all that so
talk about uh documentary filmmaking and
perception so really is it just
perception we're going after
because since truth is so there's so
many truths
everyone's reality is different yeah i
mean i don't i don't know if
we're going after anything i mean i i
think that
filmmakers who are more attuned to that
idea
um will probably make
more interesting work um
oh boy i don't i'm an opinionated guy so
i'm trying not to
um i i like there's just
i'm trying to say something about this
filmmaker is not very good but this
filmmaker is
um i i there's there's there's just
there's something about understanding
that um
[Music]
trying to present something as an
absolute
um perhaps yeah maybe it's this day and
age or
but perhaps is not the best way to sort
of get at any kind of truth
if you're trying to present sort of an
absolute thing
um because it's maybe an argument it's
not even an argument
um i don't know maybe we're just beyond
that
uh as a culture i don't know if we need
it
um there's an argument to be made that
we absolutely need it
when when you have um someone
in the most powerful position in the
world
who just is gaslighting constantly and
everyone around him is gaslighting
constantly
and so we need some sort of standard of
truth right
um but within a if we're thinking about
in terms of a film
i don't know it sometimes it feels like
it's it's lacking
um because it's so absolute i'm trying
to think of an example
where i where it shows how problematic
it is and right now and but i don't want
to
right well if you think about let's say
into the abyss herzog is showing
multiple points of view
of what happened that night you know or
thin blue line same thing what happened
that night
everybody had their own thing even west
of memphis
you know different different things and
so to me that's terribly interesting
because everybody
was showing a different version of their
own reality yeah
what's interesting i guess about it too
is that especially someone like aaron
morris
is he is but i he's figured out he's
you know the whole point of the same
blue line um
is he's figured out the truth right he's
letting us know that like okay we're
getting these different perspectives
uh and i'm gonna show you sort of these
reenactments where we get those
different perspectives sort of played
out
but then he leaves us with that audio
tape of
um whatever the guy's name essentially
confessing to the crime right
um and so there's a kind of ultimate
authority that he's taken up
with that where like i found the truth
like i was showing you all of these
variations of the truth
but here's what really happened and this
guy just admitted to it
um so there's a kind of authority or
power that he's
taking as the ultimate truth-teller
which is kind of interesting
um and part of it coming from i think
his background as a
as a private investigator you know they
think of that movie as an investigation
the way he's reenacting he's doing his
reenactment so he can see if that sort
of
holds truth in his investigation
um yeah i don't know i mean i i
think about stories we tell and and
she's
she's not coming to any conclusions
she's trying to figure out what this
family history is and
um but she's not you know there's a
whole challenge that happens have you
seen that film
i haven't it sounds good there's a whole
challenge that happens
with her and somebody else involved in
her with her family and
where he questions why she has the right
to tell this story or this part of the
story he has the
he should be telling that part of the
story it's a really fascinating thing
because kind of like what we were just
talking about earlier when i was talking
about bias
there is something about when you pick
up the camera and say i have the right
to do this um there might be a whole
bunch of other people who stand up and
say no you don't
you don't have the right to do this um
so i don't know hey i don't know if it's
what somebody should or should not do
because
i'm sure i can think of a you know march
of the penguins that's a fun film that's
completely expository you know
there's nothing wrong with that
necessarily um
so they're it's not that there's no
value in that sort of stuff i just
always find the other films more
interesting
i guess
you